Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain an American dystopian
drama film called “Fahrenheit 451.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie is set in a futuristic dystopian
world.
After the second civil war, an absolute dictatorship
of the “Ministry” took over the United
States.
Under the dictatorship, people called “Firemen”
are appointed to burn every single existing
book so people won’t get the knowledge that
the Ministry doesn’t want them to know.
The books are replaced by the Internet, called
"the 9" which consists of very limited reading
materials allowed by the ministry.
In the opening scene, we are introduced to
a fireman named Guy Montag.
He is in his futuristic house talking to an
AI that helps him dress up.
Montag has always been taught that reading
books is a crime that will cause unhappiness,
mental illness, and conflicting opinions.
He has never questioned the principles of
the Ministry and works hard as a fireman.
While getting ready, Montag listens to the
news about book reading and preserving maniacs
called the Eels.
Eels are considered criminals by law just
for trying to preserve books and the knowledge
in them.
Montag goes to work that morning to teach
the kids about the principles of the Ministry.
He and his mentor Captain John Beatty tell
the kids that the only books they should read
are the books assigned by the ministry, namely;
The Bible, To the Lighthouse, and Moby Dick.
Montag also burns two books for a demonstration
as the crowd cheers for him.
At night, they are alerted of Eels on the
move.
Beatty, Montag, and their crew of firemen
quickly drive to the location while singing
songs about their bravery.
They reach a house where a couple is trying
to upload books on the internet for everyone
to read.
The firemen quickly stop them and break their
computers.
Montag then takes them outside and insults
them in front of the reporters.
He also burns a pile of books in front of
the camera as the people watching cheer for
him.
While burning them, Montag gets flashes of
his late father.
He seizes the man’s citizenship and declares
him an Eel by law.
Later, Beatty and Montag go to a club and
meet a girl named Clarisse McClellan.
Clarisse was once declared an Eel and has
been on a restriction since then.
She asks Beatty to take a year off her restriction
in turn for reporting other Eels in the town,
and he agrees.
He and Montag go to the address she provides
and find an old man shooting a video.
The man is a civil war survivor who tells
them that firemen are supposed to put out
fires, not create them.
Beatty doesn’t believe him claiming it to
be a classic Eel lie.
However, the old man’s words strike Montag
and he begins to question if it is the truth.
The firemen have been told that the creator
of the fire department, Benjamin Franklin
has given them the right to burn.
But the man laughs at them for believing such
absurd lies fed by the ministry.
He is soon arrested and people praise firemen
for their bravery.
Before going home, Montag and Beatty go to
a bar to drink.
Montag talks about his father being a great
fireman who died while in service.
We find out that after his father’s death,
Montag was raised by Beatty who treats him
like a brother.
Later at night, Clarisse meets an informer
and exchanges a music recorder for information.
The man tells her about a house in the woods
that is a drop-off spot for books.
When Montag reaches home, he asks the AI if
firemen used to put out fires before the civil
war.
The AI declares it a lie and asks Montag if
his vitals are fluctuating.
It also suggests he take a mandatory prescribed
medicine called drops.
Montag soon gets a call from Beatty and the
two go to the house in the woods that Clarisse
has informed them about.
Inside the house is an old woman reading a
book.
She doesn’t react to the firemen breaking
in and continues reading.
They snatch the book from her to get her attention.
Just then, a fireman calls everyone upstairs
to a library containing hundreds of books.
Montag is stunned as he has never seen so
many books at once.
Beatty asks him to take in the scene before
him because he might never see something like
this again.
He also hands one of the books to the guy
and asks him to read the first line.
Montag nervously reads it but is stopped midway.
Beatty concludes it as an example of how quickly
their minds can be diverted by books.
After Beatty leaves the room, curiosity gets
the best of Montag and he secretly hides a
book under his shirt.
After that, the firemen gather all the books
downstairs and pour gasoline on them.
The old woman sits quietly the whole time
but when she is asked to move outside, she
refuses.
Instead, the lady walks in the middle of the
pile of books and burns herself with them.
Before dying he says a single word; Omnis.
Montag watches in horror as the scent of burning
flesh fills the room.
Along with him, the rest of the world also
watches the lady burn through live television.
After the commotion, Beatty is called by his
senior who accuses him of being careless.
He states that the word “Omnis” has taken
over the internet so, in the revised video
of the woman, he wants her to say “Coward”.
The following day, Montag notices the change
in the video and confronts Beatty about it.
He wants to know what the word Omnis means
and Beatty reveals that it means “everything”.
He uses the woman’s suicide as an example
to prove that reading books affects mental
health.
When Montag reaches home at night, he asks
his AI to turn off and reads the book he had
hidden.
While reading out loud, the AI corrects him
in one of the lines.
A surprised Montag asks why it didn’t turn
off when the AI replies that the conversation
is just between the two of them.
Montag doesn’t feel safe in his own home,
so he runs out quickly.
He eventually ends up in the area near Clarisse’s
house.
She first threatens him to stay away but agrees
to talk to him after seeing the book.
The two go to Clarisse’s apartment and read
the book together.
She also informs him that the ministry has
been turning people illiterate so they can
rule over them.
After the civil war, they have been slowly
killing people taking over cultures to create
a single absolute rule.
She then reveals that the drops Montag takes
every day are to wipe his childhood memories
and to make him docile so he wouldn't question
the system.
Clarisse was born to Eel parents and was an
Eel herself.
But as she grew up, she got tired of living
life on a run so she came to the city disguised
as a native.
However, she soon got bored and started smuggling
books again, only to be caught.
Hence, currently, she is in restriction.
The night ends as the two play harmonica together.
When Montag returns home, he is an entirely
different person.
He doesn’t take the drops that day, to test
if Clarisse is really telling the truth.
Because of this, he gets a flashback of the
time when he was little and his father used
to give him books.
Beatty holds a meeting the next day and reveals
that some Eels have been able to code the
knowledge of thousands of books into DNA.
That code is called the Omnis and the Eels
are planning to send the Omnis to Canada to
be distributed.
If that happens, the world will have access
to all the books ever written and the entire
purpose of the firemen will be insignificant.
To quickly find the Omnis, all the firemen
come together and collect Eels hiding throughout
the city in a warehouse.
They hit and torture the poor men for the
information but they do not budge.
Clarisse is also caught by the firemen and
brought there.
Montag quietly stays behind Beatty and observes
the people being beaten.
He catches one of the Eels trying to run away
and again get flashbacks of his past.
This time, he sees some firemen hitting his
father with a pile of books on the ground.
Back in teh present, all the Eels are kept
in a line and threatened but none of them
reveal where the Omnis is.
Suddenly, Montag switches the lights off giving
the Eels a chance to run away.
The firemen run around to catch them but Clarisse
manages to escape along with a few other Eels.
While pretending to look for them, Montag
finds a little girl and her father hiding
in a bathroom.
He simply closes the shower curtains and leaves.
However, Beatty sees him doing this and arrests
the Eels.
Later, Beatty calls Montag in his office and
furiously asks him why he pretended like he
didn’t see the criminals.
Montag says it is because of the little girl,
he felt compassionate towards the Eels, to
which Beatty replies that they often use kids
as decoys, so Montag should be tougher.
Montag then takes his jacket off and hands
it to Beatty, resigning from his position.
An enraged Beatty throws the jacket at him
claiming that he didn’t spend so much time
teaching him the Ministry’s principle for
him to resign that easily.
He threatens to burn Montag to ashes if he
ever betrays him.
After the interaction, Beatty assigns another
officer to keep an eye on Montag.
A while later, we see Montag and Clarisse
meet Clarisse is with her fellow Eel friends
who ask Montag to get in the car and drive
away.
It is evident that the Eels are not fond of
him but Clarisse assures them he is on their
side.
Meanwhile, Beatty sees a video of Montag getting
inside an Eel’s car and is furious at the
betrayal.
Montag is blindfolded and taken to a secret
Eel hideout where he meets Clarisse’s friends
and mentors.
All of them have memorized one book each so
even if they are found, the books exist forever.
To test Montag’s loyalty, they ask him to
kill a fireman they have captured.
Montag is about to stab the guy but the others
stop him, telling him that he has passed.
After finally being accepted into the team,
he is told about a young guy named Clifford.
He possesses a bird that has the DNA encoded
with the books, called the Omnis.
Clifford’s mother was the geneticist who
created Omnis and injected it into the bird.
Now, the Canadian scientists have taken responsibility
to duplicate the bird’s DNA and inject it
into every other animal in the world, so the
information inside the books can spread.
Hence, they need Montag’s help to send the
bird to a group of scientists in Canada.
Montag then meets Clifford who is a genius
with over 1300 books memorized.
Montag picks up a random book from Clifford’s
collection to test him and is pleasantly surprised
by his unique skill.
He is tasked to bring a transponder from the
fire department because the Canadian scientists
are transmitting a homing signal to find the
bird.
Unknown that Beatty knows his secret, Montag
goes to the fire department.
He walks inside the building with ease and
manages to get a transponder.
But before he can leave, he encounters Beatty.
Beatty asks him if he still wants to resign.
Montag plays along and says he is ready for
a raid.
The two gear up and drive to the supposed
raid.
But they stop in front of Montag’s home
where the media has gathered to report shocking
information about him.
Montag doesn't question anyone and simply
walks inside to find a pile of books on the
floor.
The firemen claim that the books were found
in his house and falsely accuse him of being
an Eel.
Beatty asks him to burn the books on the floor
and he obliges.
Just then, he gets a flashback of Beatty arresting
his father for owning books.
But unfortunately, he cannot do anything.
He is brought outside and declared an Eel.
Suddenly, Montag gets his hands on a gun and
manages to flee.
Clarisse picks him up in her car and the two
drive to the secret hideout.
However, before they get there, the place
is raided by the firemen.
They set fire to all the books and kill most
of Clarisse’s friends and mentors.
When Montag reaches there, he sneaks into
the burning barn and finds Clifford’s dead
body.
Thankfully, the bird is still alive inside
a cage.
As he ties a transponder to its feet, Beatty
appears behind him and asks him to stop.
Montag looks him dead in the eyes and sets
the bird free.
After it flies away, an enraged Beatty burns
Montag alive.
In the last scene, we see the bird joining
with an immense flock over Canada.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.